when you start to go back to the u.s and
you look at the 10-year two-year yield
curve uh we're negative uh we were last
negative back in 2007
2008 uh and then obviously uh kind of in
the late 80s early 90s um as well as the
2000 tech bubble bursting what is this
telling you like how much should we be
worried about this given uh
just how obvious it is that you know
this is happening
yeah so i mean really the bond market
isn't buying um isn't isn't really
buying the long-term inflationary
outlook um you're seeing front end of
the curve the two-year it's spiking up
because inflation pressures continue to
intensify but the long end of the curve
the 10-year
third year they're actually starting to
fall materially against against the
front end of the curve because of the
long-term um basically the long-term
reality of of way too much debt
and the demographic outlook which are
which are both kind of deflationary
factors when you see when you see a huge
inflationary impulse like we're saying
today paradoxically over the medium to
long term that's actually kind of a
it leads to deflationary outcomes and so
i think that's what the fed's tightening
policy is is actually doing it's setting
up for somewhat of a spectacular
deflationary bust and the bond market
is kind of smelling it out so while you
see um
earlier in the year and in 2022 the
treasury treasury bond market had the
worst start of its year in recorded
history right as duration got killed
because yields went up so so long dated
bonds long dated debt even though you
kind of can can secure in that that
nominal yield over the course of the of
the debt um
mark to market wise the bonds got killed
in value and so now you're starting to
see the the long end of the curve
relative to the short end uh you know
bond market is supposedly the smart
money um they're not buying this this
long-term inflationary outlook and
you're seeing a lot of kind of
commodities start to sniff that out as
well
when you then take a comparison like the
cpi uh year over year versus the fed
funds rate again uh pretty concerning
stuff here what is this telling us
yeah so we kind of talked about the
structural issues and the debts of gdp a
little bit earlier right so when we look
at the kind of the fed's messaging the
messaging from the treasury and just and
just look at kind of the the global debt
bubble that we knew we had coming into
this and and postcoded the reality that
central banks were facing the reason
that they wanted inflation over yields
in the first place was because debt to
gdp was so elevated so if we just skip
over one slide to slide number five real
quick
um
there's a pretty amazing stat and i
might get some of the details wrong but
of nations that have 130 debt to gdp
over the last i believe 80 years uh
there's
been 52 of them uh only japan which is
now experiencing a mass currency
devaluation hasn't defaulted on its debt
either explicitly defaulting um or
input uh kind of implicitly defaulting
through a huge spurt of inflation right
so the u.s uh debt to gdp actually in q4
of 2020 hit 136 percent
through high inflation and low interest
rates we actually got that in uh that
that the gdp number public debt to gdp
to 124
all it took was just you know eight
percent cpi uh over the course of the
year but that that was a playbook and
they actually executed it well they got
the real burden the real value of that
debt lower
but now because of that kind of
political pushback
they have to reverse course and so i
think ultimately it's it's it's not
going to last uh it's just
mathematically um
not at a reality that can persist for
long given that as the economy slows as
asset values crash you're going to see
tax receipts absolutely plummet and the
federal government and the treasury
isn't going to be able to fund itself uh
interest expense on this debt is going
to be far too high with yields at three
percent rather than say one percent or
1.5 percent so we still have this debt
spiral dynamic that a lot of people like
greg foss talk about it's just over the
short to intermediate term it's kind of
unwinding right but ultimately there is
that reality uh that that the treasury
that the us government has to fund
itself
and so i think that's that's kind of
where the long-term thesis of further
debt monetization uh money printer
gopher and the fed kind of backstopping
this entire credit system comes back
into play that long-term kind of dynamic
is is absolutely unchanged despite all
the craziness in the short term